dans les derniers épisodes on a parlé en
long en large et en travers du problème
de la surinterprétation surinterpréter
s'est expliqué ce qui n'est que le fruit
du hasard
or de telles explications se gênent et
harry souvent mal et le problème c'est
que détecter et comprendre la
surinterprétation c'est un problème très
très très difficile on a vu que la
théorie formelle de l'apprentissage
statistiques à coups de dimension wc et
d'apprentissage pack parvenait à fournir
des conditions suffisantes pour éviter
un trop grand risque de trop grande sur
interprétations notamment parlé du
théorème fondamental de l'apprentissage
statistiques et j'ai passé beaucoup de
temps à le critiquer en affirmant
notamment qu'il s'agissait d'un
formalisme restrictif et pas
universellement applicable aujourd'hui
on va voir en particulier qu'en pratique
bien souvent les datas scientiste ne
tire pas une explication d'un chapeau
d'explication car ce procédé de
sélection est précisément une cause
majeure de la surinterprétation en fait
au lieu de tirer des explications d'un
chapeau il est préférable de voir
l'apprentissage statistiques comme la
pousse d'arbre formant toute une forêt
et même si chaque arbre individuellement
sur interprète de façon assez étonnante
la forêt elle évite la surinterprétation
et devinez quoi
c'est très bel et bien comme principe
alors je présente les arbres et les
forêts comme une métaphore il en fait il
s'agit de vrais algorithmes
d'apprentissage et pour comprendre cela
on va commencer par parler des arbres un
arbre une suite de questions de sorte
que chaque question sein de l'arbre en
branche la première question est appelée
la racine de l'arbre et chaque question
qui suit correspond à ce que l'on
appelle des noeuds de l'arbre chaque ne
divise l'arbre en branche est au bout
des branches on trouve les feuilles de
l'arbre dans le cas des arbres dit de
décision chaque feuille correspond à une
décision ou une prédiction
par exemple dans le cas des chocolats
d'albert on peut construire un arbre à
deux étages
on peut d'abord se demander quel est le
type de chocolat puis pour coller aux
données lorsque la praline est au
chocolat noir il nous faut aussi nous
demander si elle contient des éclats de
noisettes l'arbre alors construit va
alors nous permettre d'effectuer des
prédictions en effet pour tout praline
il nous suffit de suivre le parcours
établi par les réponses des questions
des noeuds
l'arbre dans le cas le plus général où
les données sont décrites par des
features de grande dimension il ya une
approche pour automatiser la
construction de l'arbre prenons
l'exemple d'un espace défi jazz des
dimensions de pour déterminer une
question à se poser
on va choisir l'une des coordonnées par
exemple l'abscisse puis ce qu'on va
faire c'est couper selon abscisse de
sorte à assez bien séparer les likes des
dislike la question qui se posera à la
racine de notre arbre sera alors de
savoir de quel côté de cette coupure on
se trouve
puis pour raffiner notre classification
on peut répéter la procédure on tire à
nouveau un axe disons à nouveau la psy
ce puits pour chaque région on essaie de
couper selon l'abc ce de façon à séparer
au mieux les like des dislike et voici à
l'image la construction d'un nouvel
étage si on suppose que l'on a
maintenant tirer l'acce désordonnée
cette procédure a le bon goût de pouvoir
se complexifier à l'infini de
parfaitement se généraliser aux très
grandes dimensions et d'être calculable
très rapidement par des ordinateurs mais
les arbres ont bien sûr un gros défaut
et ce défaut est bien entendu la
surinterprétation en particulier si vous
poursuivez la découpe de l'espace
jusqu'à ce que votre arbre de décisions
coordonnées
alors vous pourrez être sûr que vous
serez en plein sur interprétations oui
parce que chaque nouvel étage de l'arbre
est une sorte d'explication haddock et
donc la dimension wc de notre chapeau
d'explication c'est en gros le nombre
maximal des tâches de l'arbre que l'on
s'autorise bon en fait c'est encore plus
compliqué que cela parce qu'il ya aussi
la question du choix de la coordonnée
sur laquelle on coupe
reste que la tentation de coller aux
données est grande et que le danger de
la surinterprétation est donc énorme et
bien dans ce genre de cas la proche
privilégié des datas scientiste ne veut
pas être de réduire la dimension vc lyon
davantage faire pousser une forêt en
fait chaque choix de l'ordre des
coordonnées sélectionné conduit à la
pousse d'un arbre différents l'idée de
l'algorithme des forêts c'est de faire
pousser tout plein d'arbres de taille
assez grande et de considérer que le
modèle retenu ne sera aucun de ces
arbres mais davantage une combinaison de
ces arbres typiquement pour effectuer
une prédiction avec une forêt on va
demander aux différents arbres d'aller
voter et on va faire de l'avis
majoritaire
la décision collective de la forêt
intuitivement il y aura alors beaucoup
moins de biais de sélection du au choix
d'une seule explication du chapeau
d'explication oui parce que souvenez
vous vous n'avez vu que le problème de
la surinterprétation notamment dans le
cas de facto nice etc avec des petites
fluctuations dans les données il en
venait à conclure tout et son contraire
alors oui de petites brises dans les
données invaliderait certains arbres de
la forêt cependant on peut espérer que
la majorité des arbres de la forêt
restera robuste aux grands changements
climatiques
si bien que malgré les changements
climatiques la position de la forêt sera
inchangé alors oui tout ce que je
commente assez juste une analogie mais
l'analogie avec la forêt et le climat
est loin d'être farfelue mais surtout de
façon cruciale
grâce à la robustesse générés par la
diversité de notre forêt on peut
t'autorise et chaque arbre à explorer
davantage de complexité en particulier
si les seules explications pas trop
mauvaise des données requiert un niveau
de complexité supérieur au nombre de
données alors la forêt pourra
s'autoriser de telles explications tout
en luttant contre la surinterprétation
en misant sur la multiplicité des
explications bien entendu ce que je dis
là des arbres est valable pour toutes
sortes d'autres algorithmes
d'apprentissage
typiquement la combinaison de plusieurs
réseaux de neurones distant réduira la
surinterprétation de chacun des réseaux
de neurones
il ya même une façon d'automatiser la
diversité des prédictions au sein même
d'un réseau de neurones via une
technique appelée drop out mais je veux
laisser ça de côté pour aujourd'hui
dans tous ces cas il s'agit de miser sur
une forêt de modèles prédictifs
différents pour gagner en robustesse et
diminuer la variance de prédiction ce
qui revient à lutter contre assure
interprétation alors on pourrait se dire
qu'en misant ainsi sur la diversité
on en vient quand même à autoriser lé
influence des moins bons modèles et en
effet c'est le cas pour permettre la
sagesse de la forêt il est nécessaire de
faire cohabiter deux grands chênes avec
de petites fougères même si ces petites
fougères ne sont pas de super
explications des données et l'astuce
pour préserver la sa graisse de la forêt
tout en permettant de faire émerger la
vie des arbres les plus pertinents c'est
de limiter l'influencé des différents
arbres en fonction de leur performance
explicative
ceci correspond à des techniques titre
dance bling de biking de boosting dont
le saint graal est un algorithme appelé
à dabou sts qui parvient à combiner de
mauvais modèle pour en faire un très bon
à dabou et gagnera ainsi le prix
goodell de 2003 qui récompense des
avancées majeures en informatique
et bien sûr comme tout algorithmes du
marché du tonnerre à davos a des
fondements très bel et bien en fait il
s'agit d'une approximation de la forme
de baisses
mais comme vous commencez à y être
habitué je veux laisser ça pour une
autre fois bref pour lutter contre la
surinterprétation contrairement à ce
qu'affirme le théorème fondamental de
l'apprentissage statistiques il n'est
pas forcément nécessaire de ne
s'autoriser qu'une explication haddock
toutes les 100 nouvelles données on peut
également s'autoriser la multiplicité
des explications et en pratique pour
résoudre de vrais problèmes cette
multiplicité des explications est
incontournable l'exemple historique de
maxi problème de prédiction est le
fameux prix netflix en 2006 netfix
disposait déjà de centaines de millions
de notes de films que des centaines de
milliers d'utilisateurs dont entrée
netflix posa le défi suivant étant donné
une fraction de ces notes que netflix
candy public prédire les autres notes
netfix promis un million de dollars pour
qui surpasserait la performance de
l'algorithme de netflix de plus de 10%
après près de trois ans de recherche de
dizaines de milliers d' équipe de dada
scientiste et après de nombreuses
péripéties qui mériterait une vidéo à
elle seule
c'est l'équipe belle corse pragmatique
chaos qui est parvenu leur solution
consistait en une jungle de 800 modèles
prédictifs différents tous plus
sophistiqués les uns que les autres
la sagesse de la forêt avaient eu raison
de tout arbre individuel donc la
diversité explicatif semble en fait
indispensable à tout système prédictif
de qualité et ça en fait d'un point de
vue philosophique
ça peut paraître assez troublant oui
parce que du coup pour qu'ils aient une
vraie diversité dans notre forêt
d'explication ces explications devront
inéluctablement se contredire et will
typiquement si je reprends mes arbres
chaque arbre est une explication
différente des données qui a en fait de
bonnes chances d'être logiquement
incompatible avec l'explication proposé
par un autre arbre autrement dit le
principe de sa graisse de la forêt nous
invite à célébrer les combinaisons de
théories incompatibles
et en particulier à rejeter toute quête
de théories utile plus étrange encore
elle semble contredire le principe de
rasoir d'occam qui semble nous inviter a
préféré la simplicité d'un arbre
explicatif à la complexité de toute
notre forêt d'explication un philosophe
pour air ainsi dire que l'espèce de
jungle mais non gêne que je semble créer
la pose des problèmes de parcimonie
ontologique
oui je me la pète un petit peu avec des
mots des trois syllabes que j'ai appris
en lisant la thèse de monsieur fille
alors qu'en fait la forêt dont je parle
ici n'est pas vraiment une jungle mis
nos gènes reste que le manque de
parcimonie de ma forêt d'explication
reste intuitivement dérangeante pour
beaucoup en particulier si notre but est
la quête de la vérité ou d'une vérité
simple et interprétable alors cette
forêt d'explication devrait vous
perturbée au plus haut point
eh bien le succès des forêts taille
d'arbustes et de belles cordes
pragmatique kaos nous pousse à rejeter
une fois de plus toute quête de la
vérité hashtag tous les modèles sont
faux certains sont utiles j'irai même
plus loin pour lutter contre la
surinterprétation la quête de la vérité
me semble profondément nuisibles
car elle nous pousse à omettre la
sagesse des forêts avant de passer aux
commentaires une petite annonce je serai
à la geek touch le 8 avril prochain à
lyon et je vous ai préparé une petite
conférence très bayésienne les neuf en a
parlé des facteurs de confusion et du
paradoxe de simpson et notamment je vous
avais demandé de réfléchir ce problème
de kanté versus radio sachant que
n'avait des statistiques qui disait que
globalement radio est meilleur que quand
tu es mais que contre tout adversaire
contre les petites équipes et contre les
grandes équipes
quand et faisait en fait toujours mieux
que radio alors comment est-ce que ça a
c'est possible et bien je vous propose
une preuve essentiellement visuel donc
je reprends le tableau qu'on avait la
dernière fois hélas que je vais faire
c'est souligner le fait qu'en fait les
matchs de radio sont contre des petites
équipes et les matches de caen tesson
contre des grosses équipes et du coup le
pourcentage de victoires de kanté est
essentiellement ce pourcentage de
victoires contre des grandes équipes
alors que le pourcentage de victoires de
rillieux est essentiellement celui
contre des petites équipes
alors y en a plusieurs dans les
commentaires qui ont fait remarquer
qu'ils avaient trouvé ça très rapidement
avoir une explication
félicitations à vous bravo alors si vous
avez trouvé très très rapidement en fait
c'est un petit peu dommage parce que
fait bien on se rencontrent des
difficultés de ce prêt mais si on me
résous trop rapidement on se rend pas
forcément compte que ce problème était
en prob extrêmement difficile et donc
notamment pour ceux qui ont trouvé 1 ère
fois mais pour tout le monde je vous
propose un autre problème de
compréhension du paradoxe de simpson
alors si vous passez dans les années 80
il veut une étude sur est ce que le
tabac causé plus de décès et du coup
j'ai fait une étude épidémiologique
verts qui sont les sondés de nombreuses
personnes ils les ont suivis pendant 20
ans et ceux qui ont découvert c'est
qu'au cours de ces vingt années le taux
de décès était plus grand chez les non
fumeurs que chez les fumeurs et du coup
la question à laquelle j'aimerais qu'on
réfléchisse et c est ce que ça veut dire
que du coup fumée c'est bien pour la
santé
ou est-ce qu'il n'y aurait pas un
facteur de confusion et si oui quel est
ce facteur de confusion
encore une fois essayé de ne pas spoiler
la réponse dans les commentaires
il veut même troller un maximum en ne
vous donnant jamais la réponse à cette
question
elle existe quelque part sur internet
dans une vidéo youtube qui est dans un
des liens de l'une de mes vidéos ouvert
pas facile à trouver mais ce que je veux
c'est que vous vous rendiez compte
vraiment que trouver le facteur de
confusion dans ce cas c'est extrêmement
difficile et il est alors incroyablement
tentant de croire dans la statistique et
de croire du coup on fait que fumer est
bénéfique pour la santé
bon je me permets quand même donné un
petit indice en gros pour trouver les
facteurs de confusion à chaque fois il
faut absolument se demander s'il n'ya
pas une différence a priori entre par
exemple les matches qu'on joue et radio
et quand est ce qui n'aura pas une
différence a priori
promesses qui ont été faites par obama
ou trump ou encore à ce qu'il n'y aura
pas une différence a priori entre les
lycées financer et ici qui ne sont pas
financés fait la clairon pour comprendre
le paradoxe de simpson s'est essayé de
raisonner avec ses a priori et c'est
trés bayésiens tout ça enfin fort bien
et antoine roussel font remarquer il ya
une grosse erreur de calcul dans la
vidéo restantes
désolé vous est demandé de vérifier les
calculs un moment de la vidéo et si vous
l'avez bien fait vous devriez avoir vu
que en fait dans mes notes
le nombre de lycées favoriser financé et
est égal à quinze mille et pas à 5000
fait que les résultats sur un feuille
mais à l'écran ça la fout mal
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
que la sagesse des forêts vous fera
réfléchir notamment quant à
l'épistémologie la philosophie des
sciences de façon plus générale parce
que je pense que laurence a des
implications à ce niveau là
la prochaine fois on va parler de
l'autre solution utilisée par les
praticiens des machines erding pour
pouvoir éviter assure interprétation
sans diminuer les dimensions wc de leurs
modèles à savoir la régularisation
notamment pour vous préparer pour la
semaine prochaine vous pouvez vous poser
la question suivante
imaginez que vous étudiez un phénomène
et vous disposer d'assez peu de données
mais il ya énormément de cause possible
de la conséquence que vous observez du
coup comment est ce que vous pouvez
faire pour déterminer la cause sachant
qu'il ya beaucoup plus de cause possible
que de données que vous observez parce
qu'il ya quand même un moyen
d'identifier quelles sont les causes les
plus probables ou quelque chose comme ça
sachant que si on fait typiquement de la
régression linéaire dans ce cas là on
risque fort d'être foutu et de pas
réussi à refaire cette agression il ya
ce genre de cas c'est typiquement le cas
de l'analyse de l'adn savoir quels sont
les facteurs de risque au niveau du code
génétique des tic en personne comment
est ce que le code génétique influence
les risques de l'hôtel maladie ça c'est
un problème majeur qui s'est posé avec
le séquençage notamment de là
et ce sont des quelques on appelle le
typiquement large prisme inspire
beaucoup de paramètres beaucoup de
causes possibles toutes les valeurs des
nucléotides deux adn sont
potentiellement des causes imaginable
mais on a peu de haine on a peu de
donner à ce que le nombre de données
qu'on dispose est très inférieur au
nombre de lettres dans son plan
d'affaires laisse un petit peu réfléchir
à tout ça si vous avez aimé cet épisode
penser à le lac et à le commenter le
phare faisait penser à vous avez des
futurs épisodes merci aux outils
performants et j'espère que vous serez
là la prochaine fois besides the used in
the famous et de boost à gauche et
easyjet reasons eelv en 2012
on y perd en dessous koulou week end
risque reste une autre relative prison